Time for Action
climate activists targeting wax works of
the royal family today
just stop oil and other campaign groups
have increasingly been attacking art as
a way of shocking the public and drawing
heavy criticism in the process
but Vanessa nakite one of the world's
most prominent climate activists says we
should get our priorities right for me
if I'm to choose fighting for an art
piece or fighting for a child who is
starving I will fight for a child who is
starving because I saw that happening
and it's destructive though isn't it
it's just destructive for the sake of it
that's the criticism how I wish the
thought of a child starving would cause
the same reaction and get people to
speak up and get people to do something
about the climate crisis nakite was once
famously erased from a photo with other
white campaigners cropped out in the
final published version
but she is hard to ignore now and just
weeks ahead of the cop 27 un climate
Summit in Egypt she is unforgiving
the UK thinks of itself as a climate
leader but it is expanding drilling for
new oil and gas in the North Sea and it
has lifted a ban on fracking for Shale
gas what do you think of that climate
leadership is not calling oneself a
leader it is real action but if the UK
continues to open new coal oil and gas
infrastructure then the UK is known a
climate leader is it failing in your
view it's failing not only the people
it's failing the planet as well I am not
the UK prime minister I am Vanessa
nakati a climate activist I have makate
and other campaigners are using
increasingly sophisticated techniques to
get people to listen including this deep
fake video of Liz truss the aim to get
rich Nations to pay poor ones for the
damage they've caused
people are losing things that they
cannot get back things that they cannot
you know you can't adapt to the loss of
your culture or your traditions in the
end histories are being destroyed
the costs of climate disasters continue
to mount but extracting more money from
Nations dealing with their own problems
is quite another matter and one that
won't be resolved quickly
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News
[Music]